foreign
there should be great excitement here at
the Clapham Grand soon the country
reopens without restrictions and this
iconic venue should be packed again but
instead there is anxiety
soaring infections mean many of the
young Workforce are isolating
I've currently got 12 members of staff
that can't come to work who are all
track and Trace and isolating they don't
have covid they've just been notified by
the app you know I'm an independent
venue with a Workforce of around 30 to
35 people so I'm looking at 30 of my
Staffing dropped out in two days if
realistically the government wants any
Hospitality they need to open
at full capacity we need the workforce
to support that the new health secretary
says double vaccinated people will no
longer need to self-isolate from August
the 16th and this exemption will extend
to anyone under 18.
he also warned infections could reach
100
000 a day by the summer but says the
vaccine data gives him confidence with
some 27 000 lives saved this pandemic is
far from over and we will continue to
proceed with caution but we're
increasingly confident that our plan is
working and that we can soon begin a new
chapter based on the foundations of
personal responsibility and Common Sense
rather than the blunt instrument of
rules and regulations
at this vaccine Center in York people
are divided on the government's lifting
of restrictions including the wearing of
masks
we don't actually want them to tell us
what position shouldn't be doing we need
to sort of make our own mind and talk
about that I think I just want to keep
an eye on probably it's a personal
choice they've been crowded places but
you know otherwise I'll be happy to get
rid of it I think
foreign
the government also wants us to return
to our places of work
the mayor of London City Khan wants
commuters to carry on wearing face masks
an example of emerging divisions
the grand the preparations continue
fear here is after making it this far
opening night might not happen at all
oh she's Josh's Sky News in South London